foreign
ER in Memphis Tennessee what's up Parker
John freaking deloney Parker freaking
Parker what's up dude
I don't know if your last name is
your last name Parker too please
yes this is the best part okay
okay hold on dude I keep interrupting
you what'd you say
I said I can't believe I'm talking to
the best mental health expert on the
best mental health podcast ever
yes okay so real quick clarification I'm
not even close to the best mental health
professional but this is the best show
right I'm not even the top 200 dude not
top 2000. I'm not very good come on man
give yourself but we got a dope podcast
all right make sure you talk uh directly
into your phone
um okay so what's up life all right
yeah it's good I practiced that intro
like 20 times and apparently my phone
cut out so that's good all right do it
again
I can't believe I'm talking to the
greatest mental health expert on the
greatest mental health podcast ever dude
so we established this earlier but I'll
say it again
um
I I'm not really good at being the a
mental health expert I'm not very good
but this is the greatest show of all
time ever you did nail that one yeah so
yeah so what's up Parker how can I help
hey real quick what belts are you in jiu
jitsu oh dude I was trained by a guy who
did all his training in Japan and then
my other coach was from mainland China
both of them believed that belts were
for American kids to feel good about
themselves into past anyway they had a
whole thing against belts so no belts
for me dude oh
okay now I've never heard that before
that's awesome well I mean it would be
really cool if I had a belt hanging from
but I would have been not very far along
I got you I got so cool but in my heart
super black belt dude
no sir 100 man yes
so what's up okay so my question is man
um
did I set my son up for a life of
anxiety yes um I'll give you a backstory
okay
um when I was about you know 11 or 12 I
had like
these big big dreams of being like uh in
the UFC doing MMA and all that stuff
and um if I start rambling just let me
know just interrupt me have you ever
have you ever listened to the show
before
I have yeah yeah yeah yeah I ramble a
lot natural Rambler too so there you go
you're in good company all right go for
it
all right so like all my life I had
these dreams of being this uh the next
Conor McGregor or Michael Chandler or
something like that and um
to be honest I I've done martial arts my
whole life and
um
I started to get distracted I had a I
got a wife I got married and I had a kid
and when I had my first kid I was like I
didn't really try hard enough because it
was MMA thing so I'm gonna try it
and so I accumulated a record of like
three and two which is not you know not
amazing but it's uh I had potential and
then I got my then I had a second kid
and um around that time I decided I was
like I don't think I need to get get
punched in the face all the time and not
get paid for it so
I decided to quit the quit the you know
pursuit of MMA and
when that happened I I started I felt
this hole in my heart
where martial arts had been my whole
life
and so I started started filling that
with alcohol
and it was kind of like a
kind of a slow start you're losing a
one-two drinks here or there and then it
turned into every weekend
and then it turned into like
every time every you know every time I
was awake I was either buzzed or had
anxiety
and um
my now five-year-old he was you know he
was in for all of that and so I became
you know very I became like a ticking
Time Bomb I was
um
just always yelling always screaming I
was kind of just like you said in your
book Radioactive
and um
at the beginning of 2022 I decided to
really you know get control of my life
back
um I've lost about 40 pounds I stopped
drinking and
um really started you know working on
myself so I can do better for my family
and then a couple of days ago I was on I
was on Tick Tock and uh I saw this Mel
Robbins interview that with a
neuroscientist that said um
80 of your
um 80 of your childhood development
starts at like between zero and five
years old and
man I almost dropped my phone because I
was like
I was
such a such a hot head such a
such a radioactive person between his
zero and five
and so my question to you is did I set
him up for a life of anxiety and if I
did what can I do to
you know help him navigate through his
life yeah that's a great question man
thanks for telling that story I wasn't
rambling at all that was I was really
good man uh okay cool and we track a lot
um
some of my story is very similar I got
into the reason I got into mixed martial
arts initially
was because I ran my mouth so much
and I always found myself every time I
went out with my buddies every time I
played a pickup basketball game and I
had friends that were nuts and they
loved fighting and so I found myself
a disconnect between how much I ran my
mouth and what I knew deep down I was
not capable of doing
and so I went I began my journey there
really
um to wallpaper over a very insecure
little boy that had now suddenly found
himself inside of a man's body
and my dreams I never dreamed of being
professional I was never I was never the
thing I liked going to the gym every
night with I think at one point the
state kickboxing heavyweight champion
was there the light heavyweight champion
was there some just some Killers man and
then when the China won the Olympics and
they started running through San shoo
Fighters it was I mean some of the
craziest athletes in the world and it
was awesome
and I felt myself transition from this
scared little boy who was trying to Bow
up and show everybody
to
um
the most peaceful calm guy I could
possibly be and so I I'm a firm believer
my my kids are getting involved in it
soon like I'm a firm believer in martial
arts over the Long Haul because I think
it takes some of that nonsense out of
you
so the first thing I would ask you is
this is a private conversation for you
and yourself
was any of that dream any of that
lifelong journey mixed martial arts in
martial arts was any of that a way to
run from something you thought you were
not it might not be
but I think this it wasn't okay
um that's where I would start because
that that was for me
I
here's the uh um
here's a challenge scientists face
many things can be true at the same time
and it's very hard to digest that in the
public
and so while what Mel Robbins and the
neuroscientists said is accurate
an unfathomable a fathomable amount of
neurodevelopment happens from zero to
five
tons and tons and tons of I mean your
brain is literally growing itself you
may have heard this but
um
really the first 18 months of a kid's
life is really considered the Third
uh I mean the fourth trimester you can't
really have a trimester but
um the brain's not done developing yet
baby humans just have their babies early
and so all that to say is that's true
and
genetic dispositions are true and none
of that is causal none of that is
deterministic that's also true
and what that means is
when somebody is as loving and wise as
you
who's able to go whoa I don't like the
set of train tracks I'm on
the beauty is a there's messages like
that that get your attention and B
there's light and hope in the next set
of train tracks you put you and your
family on
yeah so I want you to sleep well at
night now I'll be totally honest with
you if you keep going the same way
you've been going absolutely your kid's
gonna reflect your
um
angst your rage it being uh the child of
an alcoholic is evil dude because you're
there in per in body but you're not
there in person in spirit
um and a kid feels lost right so all
that's true you do nothing yes
so I'm gonna tell you what just happened
at my house okay this is me just being
vulnerable with you
yeah
um I and this is it's it's a shameful
thing for me because I do this for a
living okay and it's so cool to talk to
people about their parents and their
marriage and their kids and all that and
then I got parents and I'm married and I
got kids and so I get to live at home
and see if this actually works or not
so
um
I had a really gnarly interaction with
my daughter
she just I'm probably getting choked up
here
um
uh she she wouldn't let me tuck her in
at night she just said no and to the
point that she was screaming and crying
like it was a big mess and at first I
was just trying to get my wife a night
off or two nights off or three nights
off
and then I was like hey I just want to
hug my daughter and she's she's seven
she wouldn't do it
and then it became like for after
breakfast before she went to school like
they can have a hug before you go to
school and she would just look at me and
walk away
and then my inner Texas male was like
that's disrespectful and I'm this and
you need to
like I'm your father like that all that
stuff yeah
and
I call a buddy of mine's a counselor and
she gave me some good wisdom and then my
wife said something that was really
powerful
um and it reminded me back of a Gabor
mate book that I read and that's it's I
think one of the most important uh books
ever written about parenting it's called
hold on to your kids
but here's what he says
be likable
and maybe your seven-year-old little
girl doesn't not like her dad in fact
she loves him deeply but she feels that
energy on off his like pulsing out of
you
and suddenly I wrote about it in the
book I realized oh crap I've become old
me again
I'm a nuclear reactor I'm always hot I'm
always coming in late I'm always flying
around the place I'm always just right
on edge right on edge right on edge
and I'm gonna tell you this dude
um I went and at the same time I had a
boss uh someone I work with tell me that
I'm really hard to be friends with not
because I'm not a nice guy I tell the
truth all that I'm just a lot I just
overwhelm people
um all the time
so then I did something that the Texas
male and me never thought would happen
and I decided I'm going to try to be
really likable and what that meant was I
had to be very peaceful and what that
meant was I had to start just changing
the way I experienced the world the way
I thought about things what I did what I
ate how much I slept all that stuff
this morning
let me get chucked up
this morning my wife had to peel my
daughter off of me because we were
having a hug off competition
okay so I want you to have peace in your
soul it can change
what you're going to want to do is come
up with a program or what are the 10
steps too and I don't think that's the
map back to a kid's heart to a
non-anxious kid
what you're gonna have to do is decide I
want to have a non-anxious life on a
non-anxious house
that means we've got to own reality that
means we got to choose Freedom we're not
going to owe people money we're not
going to be like you're going to set
yourself up in a position over the next
three to five years where you can quit
at any time
a job if you've got a toxic boss or
somebody asking you to do something you
don't want to do you're going to take
care of your body y'all are going to get
connected to something bigger than
yourself you're going to practice
mindfulness you're going to create a
non-anxious life for yourself
and your kids will become that
I believe that with all my heart
yeah and that's that's what I've been
working on this year or this on 2022s
you know trying to my best to live an
unacious life it's it's difficult it's
real hard it's real hard okay and I know
that
um
I want to challenge you on a couple of
things okay I'm going to give you a
couple things I want you to try with
your kid and I'm gonna challenge you in
a couple things and I'm gonna give you
some tools I'll put my money where my
mouth is okay
um I want you with your five-year-old to
start a journal with him on his bed just
go to Walgreens and buy like a crappy
spiral
and it might be a picture
of Daddy's smiling and with an over I
want you to draw like an over like the
smile extra big
no it might be like a heart
and just put on his pillow and his job
is to write to you before he goes to
school the next day
and color in it or whatever that looks
like okay I want you to start that
practice the second one is
really practice just being around them
let them know that you like them
every moment is not a teaching moment
every second is not a life lesson
everything is not like uh hey you need
to pick this up why are you doing like
that you need to dry off why are you
doing that are you gonna wear deodorant
like he's only five I know yeah
um
it's like just like being around your
kid yes there's some things you got to
tell them to do but
if you get angry which you will if you
don't get angry you should probably go
see a psychiatrist because that's not
normal
um yeah I want you to take a knee and
look your kid in the eye and say I'm
choosing anger right now and this is not
about you and I'm sorry if I scared you
I'm not sorry that I'm angry
but I'm sorry that I scared you good but
daddy's not angry at you
okay I want you to teach him there's a
difference between your anger and him
okay
um touch him on his face every single
day hold his face if you can
I told my kid when he was really little
I'm gonna hug you every day of your life
and it's gonna be weird sorry but not
sorry
yeah okay
um
maybe a secret breakfast date does he go
to school yet
yeah he's from pre-k so he gets off
usually like 11 or so
if y'all had like a
I take my son to Waffle House once a
week
and it's become magic time because it'll
be nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing and then suddenly he's like hey
Dad can we talk about something and I've
created a world where that's okay
because it happens regularly right
here's what I'm gonna do for you I'm
gonna send you um a couple of things I'm
gonna send you
the full Financial Peace University I
work here at Ramsey solutions to help
you and your family get out of debt any
money you owe anybody else we're gonna
walk I'm gonna give you the plan to get
out of debts help millions of people do
it I'm gonna give it to you for free
okay
come on man you got to watch your
lessons and you got to do it is that
fair
sure okay also I'm gonna send you my
buddy um Lane Norton's carbon app I get
no money from this it's the app I use
um to keep track of my diet nutrition
and it's been a it's a it's the best
there is okay also I'm gonna send you
the newest workout from my buddies over
at mind pump it's their maps and about
anabolic program uh advanced okay you
gotta get your butt back in the gym
cool yes sir
um and I think a great gift you could
give your kid is to start going back to
jiu jitsu classes and not doing it
because I'm going to be Conor McGregor
but doing it because I want to be able
to roll around with my grandkids when
I'm 90.
oh yeah and I have been we've been in uh
we've been in a weird season of life
where we're in the middle of a house
renovation so it's that's eating up all
of our time but yeah I've been in the
gym
quite a bit but good well I'm gonna send
you some stuff okay and um hang on the
line here and Jenna's gonna get it to
you these things I'm telling you taking
care of your body taking care of your
nutrition taking care of your finances
taking care of your calendar
um taking care of you your marriage all
those things dude create a non-anxious
household and it lets your little boys
and your second kid know
Come What May in here I'm safe
and with that guy I'm safe so everybody
listen and hear me yes
much much of your neurodevelopment
happens from zero to five I think that's
probably accurate
and
neuroplasticity is a thing that will
last with you through your lifetime
so it's never too late
to reconnect with your kids it's never
too late to reconnect with your spouse
it's never too late to reconnect with
your friends it's never too late to
reconnect with yourself
you can always get off the train tracks
that you're on
if you have to just start walking
another Direction
but you can get on another set of train
tracks and head off into Adventures
unknown
you can always start again thanks for
your call my brother